s
survenu au Canada.
25 ans plus tard, la communauté
a tenu ie Sauvageau.
- L'Action de grâce a toujours
été un dur moment à passer
à Saint-Bernard.
GEORGETTE BILODEAU,
- L'Action de grâce,
ce n'est pas de la tristesse,
c'est de la joie,
c'est de l'émerveillement,
mais pour nous, ça vient
cet événement-là.
- Mais 25 ans après la tra
qui a fauché la vie de 43
de ses citoyens et de leur
chauffeur, la communauté
chapitre.
SAMUEL LABRECQUE,
petit-fils de victimes
- Ça fait juste rappeler
de vieux souvenirsil n'y a pil s
juste ça qui arrive là,
il y a d'autres choses,
il y a du positif qui arrive.
- Michel Leblond oeuvrait
à l'égl cérémonies
anniversaires, il en a vécu
plusieurs, mais il estime
que celle-ci devrait être
la dernière.
e Saint-Bernard
- Il y a une génération qui est
passée, passée, passée, passée,t
boucler la boucle. On a choisi
de choisir la vie. Alors,
il s'est passé de belles choses
célébrer.
- À la demande de la communauté,
le père Marc-André Lachance
a officiavoir céavoir céavoir cs
des victimes.
MARC-ANDRÉ LACHANCE, prêtre
- Il y a eu quatre cérémonies
où il
un à côté de l'autre.
- 43 bougies à la mémoire
arus; et le cierge,
allumé par la dernière
survivante, pour symboliserté.
- Moi, ce matin, j'ai un peu
de personnes qui vont s'être
ajoutées : des enf
des petits-enfants. Je pense
qu'après 25 ans, ça va être
grand événement dans l'église.
- C'est toute la vie qui est
venue depuis ce temps-là,
parce que c'est une génération.
il y a plein de petits-enfants
qui sont nés.
- Georgette Blondeau a perdu
dans l'accident.
- Il y a une belle solidarité
qui s'est installée. C'est comme
ça qu'on a passé au travers.
prévue, aux Éboulements,
ccident s'est produit.
Une minute de silence sera
observée à 13 h 50, l'heure
Ici Flavie Sauvaganada, Saianad